et notre invité ce matin pour cette
émission spéciale décision du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est Dominique Rousseau
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
constitutionnalistes professeur de droit
public à l'Université Paris 1 Panthéon
Sorbonne on va évidemment parler de
cette décision avec vous d'abord je vais
vous demander Dominique Rousseau votre
avis quel est selon vous la décision la
plus probable ce soir
constitutionnel je suis pas la petite
souris qui écouterait aux portes ou sous
le plancher non je n'en sais rien en
tant que juriste c'est vrai que je
dirais que objectivement il y a des
grillés d'inconstitutionnalités sérieux
qui pourrait je dirais pas qui devra
mais qui pourrait conduire à
l'annulation totale de total de la loi
quelles sont ces grèves écoutez le
principal c'est d'avoir choisi l'article
47 pour faire cette réforme c'est à dire
d'avoir choisi la voix d'une loi de
financement certificative de la sécurité
sociale alors que le contenu de la loi
actuelle porte sur les principes
fondamentaux d'un régime de retraite or
l'article 34 excusez-moi de faire la
technique mais l'article
34 dit la loi détermine les principes
fondamentaux de du droit du travail et
de la sécurité sociale or fixer l'âge de
la retraite c'est un principe
fondamental supprimer les régimes
sociaux c'est l'organisation des
principes fondamentaux d'un régime de
retraite la pénibilité c'est un principe
fondamental la question des des
carrières hachées notamment pour les
femmes ça fait partie des principes
fondamentaux d'un régime de retraite
autrement dit le véhicule législatif
comme comme vous dites la voix
procédurale choisie pour cette réforme
n'est pas la bonne je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le
Premier ministre Edouard Philippe en
2019 avait choisi la loi ordinaire pour
réformer les retraites par point marison
Touraine el khomri et River toutes les
réformes du régime des principes du
régime des retraites c'est fait par la
loi ordinaire là le gouvernement a pris
la voix de l'article 47 c'est-à-dire les
lois de financement rectificatives or
c'est pas fait pour ça
la loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale c'est fait pour
modifier le cas échéant les objectifs de
dépenses de la sécurité sociale là c'est
pour définir les principes pérennes du
régime des retraites 64 suppression des
régimes spéciaux etc donc il y a une
erreur si vous voulez de procédure
[Musique]